now claims by President Trump and other
elected Republican officials about
widespread voter fraud have been
repeatedly debunked but now this week
some real evidence of fraud has finally
emerged accepted involves fraud
allegedly committed by Republicans on
behalf of a Republican candidate for
Congress in North Carolina going to
Washington
to be your voice in the ninth
congressional district Republican Mark
Harris declared victory in the
congressional election last November he
won by just 905 votes amidst allegations
his staff had stuffed the ballot boxes
with fraudulent absentee ballots this
week at a special hearing of the North
Carolina State Election Board those
allegations appear to have been
confirmed a campaign worker Lisa Britt
testified she was paid $125 for every 50
absentee ballots she collected and then
filled in for Republican candidates or
throwing away any marked for Democrats
I assume you knew that it was not I
understand you but you were paid to do
something that you knew was wrong so
it's not like you only since the
election figured out that was wrong you
knew at the time you were voting other
people's ballots it was wrong yes and he
knew was illegal and if that weren't a
shady enough many of the absentee
ballots that were delivered were signed
by the same eight people including three
of them who signed their name more than
40 times and I'm being told we have one
of the ballots it was signed by Hugh G
election fraud
[Applause]
late today the State Election Board of
North Carolina voted unanimously to
order a new election based on the
evidence they have uncovered a voter and
election fraud I'm joined now by Matthew
Dunlap the Secretary of State in Maine
and one of the Democrats appointed to
serve on president Trump's Commission on
election integrity a group that was
disbanded after only two meetings
mr. Dunlap let me ask by asking you
start by what happened in North Carolina
what do you think of that well I think
the bottom line is the process worked in
the end probably not the way we would
have wanted to see it work you always
want the voters to have the last say in
terms of who their representatives are
going to be but nonetheless you know the
the chain of custody procedure is at
North Carolina and so many other states
like Maine employ did went out the day
the the misdoing was discovered and
remedy is unfortunately a new election
but the voters will finally have the
last say in this election you wrote an
op-ed in The Washington Post saying
where's the outrage from those talking
about election fraud what do you mean
well when I was on the presidential
Advisory Commission on election
integrity some of the members were quite
striked about the rampant voter fraud
historically sweeping across the country
even though there's been almost no
prosecutions of such voter misconduct
they said that he's done the less
rampant and that we needed to tighten up
our election laws in order to prevent
voter fraud what we saw in North
Carolina was not voter fraud it was
actually election fraud perpetrated by
election election workers volunteers and
paid consultants not by voters so what
was striking to me was that those same
people that were beating their chests so
vmon Lee
trying to change election laws prevent
voter fraud have been very strangely
silent about what's been happening in
North Carolina which i think is actually
quite telling but in terms of widespread
voter fraud did you find any we found
none in fact in the state of Maine and
I've been Secretary of State this is my
13th year we've had two suspected cases
of voter misconduct that were forwarded
to the attorney general's office
they weren't prosecuted because
basically the people just didn't know
what they were doing they were making
mistakes not trying to commit crimes and
I think that's that's a that's what we
see around the country is confusion not
not criminal misconduct by voters
American citizens care about their
elections and that was borne out and the
the whole public discourse around the
Commission's work that I was proud to be
a part of bringing down actually
unfortunately we had a chance to do some
good work and it was completely
undermined by this Phantom Menace that
the vampire hunters keep chasing well
this stuff never what you think to
toughen voter registration rules and
laws I don't think it will I think
that's going to be an ongoing debate
we've been debating it in Maine and
across the country now for many many
years about that balance between the
access of a voter to the ballot and the
security of that ballot and it is a very
fine balance I think we do a great job
across the country and maintaining those
balances some states take more stringent
approaches to these things than than
others and but there's a reason why a
state like Maine for example is one of
the leaders in voter turnout around the
country it's because we have that access
balanced by security so this notion of
widespread voter fraud you just don't
find it at all it's sort of like razor
blades and apples around Halloween you
hear about it every year but it never
really seems to happen now that I think
that mr. Dunlap thank you for joining us
from Maine tonight very much appreciate
it